after years of wrangling chile's
congress has passed a bill allowing
same-sex couples to marry and adopt
children until now gay couples could
only enter into a civil union once the
bill is signed by the president chile
will become the seventh latin american
country to legalize same-sex marriage
have been anxiously awaiting the
approval of the marriage equality bill
it will also allow same-sex couples to
adopt children
something fundamental for many families
and for children like the sun
maximiliano
today maximiliano only has one legally
recognized mother that's me that means
if i die my family members would have
custody of him in that case he would
have to move to another house his right
to his family identity would be violated
this is the most extreme case but the
fact that the state recognized our
partnership but not us as a family unit
left us exposed
if we as a couple broke up for example i
would not have the legal right to take
care of my son
he would not be able to demand for
example child support for me
velamur of the lgbtq advocacy group
igualis has been a driving force behind
the bill the legislation had been
delayed by conservative parties who see
marriage only as the union of a man and
a woman
if marriage was not the social and legal
institution that grants more benefits
and protections
perhaps the lgbtq population
would not have to fight for this right
but that is the case the fact that
people can now get married and feel
protected before the law is a tremendous
step in this country
polls show that more than 70 of the
population in chile approves of marriage
equality as well as adoption by same-sex
couples
this dignifies us as a country we as a
country can no longer make this
distinction because we are committed to
the idea that everyone needs to have
better access to rights better access to
opportunities and equality before the
law
those are the things that are
particularly important in chile
rosanna have been together for nine
years they signed a civil union
agreement four years ago but that did
not include equal parental rights the
legal recognition that maximiliano has
two mothers
now the three of them will be able to be
a family before the law
obviously we want to get married
a moment they've long been waiting for
well dw's benjamin alvarez grouper joins
me in the studio to discuss this further
this is a landmark a law but the
same-sex marriage bill was brought in in
2017. why has it taken why has this
taken so long to be implemented there's
been a lot of opposition by conservative
politicians and by conservative parties
this was the law was first presented in
2017 by then president mitchell bachelet
is now the u.n human rights chief but
there was a lot of opposition and the
catholic church played a very important
role and still is playing an important
role it is swifting but still chile is a
very conservative country
when it comes to that so earlier this
year when the conservative president
sebastian piner said the time has come
for
this bill and also for equal marriage in
chile he won praise but also criticism
from within his government coalition to
push further for this law and now today
both chambers gave the green light and
he will sign it and then it will be the
law that two
people of the same sex can get married
so is this an indication of significant
change in chile and its society it shows
indeed that chile is more open to
liberal laws and to progress when it
comes not only to lgbtq rights but also
for example when it comes to abortion a
few years ago chile had a total ban on
abortion and now it's allowed in certain
circumstances so it shows that there has
been a shift in the society but not
everyone is a very big fan of this new
law next week and there will be
presidential elections and one of the
two candidates far-right candidate jose
antonio cass
has criticized is not only an opponent
to same-sex marriage he has called lgbtq
ngo's organization part of the gay lobby
and won the la moner the presidential
palace was illuminated with the rainbow
colors he said that the presidency had
basically surrendered to a gay
dictatorship whatever that means he will
face
a left wing a presidential candidate
he's called gabriel boris who has
praised this vote today and said that
under his government
the lgbtq community will have also full
of rights during the government but it
shows of course that there's also that
the people still opposing
this measure josenton augusta for a
candidate even went further by saying
that the children of same-sex couples
could even sue the state for not giving
them the right to have a mother and a
father so the majority of chileans is
indeed in favor of the new law but there
is indeed opposition and high-ranking
politicians that are still against it
all right ben thank you very much